all right y'all the hour is almost up
but I have one last story that might
make you smile this is what I'm
liking so generally by 2 years old kids
might know a few numbers by memory but
rarely do they know what they mean or
how they work that's probably why social
media has been blowing up since since
they've all seen a 2-year-old Devon see
what he can do just look at this is
incredible
e
[Music]
e like what is this kid going to do with
his life we have that little genius on
the line right now along with his daddy
Dwayne they watch on NBC New York what's
up y'all how how y'all doing doing
hey hi say
hi Oh Dwayne you have a little genius
like how did you discover this well at
four months old we started showing Devin
numbers and we noticed when uh we would
change the channel on the shows he would
start to cry and when we would change it
back he would stop crying and also his
first word was seven so we thought that
was pretty cool um also at one we would
we would have him we bought him a a
Writing
Tablet we bought him a writing
tablet and um we were practice writing
numbers from one to 100 while holding
his hands and saying it out loud so soon
after that he was able to uh write
numbers all on his own I mean it's cool
how the brain works right and we're all
so different so let's try a little
equation so we're here in 30 Rock in
studio 6A so
Devin Devon what is 30 time six can you
do it 30 time six I'm about to be blown
away
30 time six count
it count
it like I'm
like DAV you are
incredible
yes he's like man this is just a Tuesday
I'm killing it on a tues like oh my
thank you so much this is incredible I
cannot wait to see what he does with his
life I mean God so he's just so Advanced
that's incredible thank you Dwayne for
sharing this thank you
[Music]
Devin I'm liking y'all's post right now
right and that's not all our season long
partner pilot pin makers of friction the
go-to erasable pin of the Kelly Clarkson
show love how you're supporting Devon in
all the ways so they're going to give
youall $1,000 just for being red
wow thank you thank you bye y'all have
such a great holiday season thank you to
all our guests this hour Paris Hilton
Ben Marshall John Higgins Martin hurle
Marlo Thomas Shane Cherry Soler glater
and Lawrence Darion y'all have a great
day and if it's not trying change
[Music]
it
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home